this is what i have to say about the
debates last night paul
um i'll say um at the very least what we
learned
is that uh america is in good shape
dude i gotta tell you something that was
i just tweeted out the government owes
me 90 minutes back
i giannis if i watched a car
run over a puppy it would be the same
feeling
i was disgusted i was embarrassed
i was cringing i was counting the
minutes for that
absolute [ __ ] storm to be over
the the interrupting each other the
monterey the moderator chris ross i mean
he had nothing he couldn't he couldn't
control it he was like trying to stay in
the middle of
two kids arguing in high school um
trump was a disaster just interviewing
young talking about things that didn't
matter biden looked a little slow
i mean the whole thing was just these
are our choices
we are [ __ ] dude we are we could curse
on this thing no
oh of course yeah i mean yeah i didn't
it was like watching the episode of the
real housewives new jersey i mean it was
[ __ ] well the most
i think probably the most coherent part
was about was about joe biden's son
hunter doing a little blizzy i mean the
kid liked to do a little white lady the
kid liked to go skiing
he liked cocaine but let me just say
this if you think for one second
that trump's two boys haven't done a
little blow
in their day and probably a little blow
with hunter biden at like cow in new
york city at some point
then you got another thing coming those
kids like blow
there's no way they all don't do blow or
have done blow
i mean that's like the least of the i
was more concerned with
how really nothing got talked about did
you get anything from that
did you get anything from that like as
far as policies
did you get anything as far as like
getting educated on what's coming in the
future or did you get
you did this it would be a disaster if
you were you're the worst president ever
you're racist
i mean it was just it was actually
really it's almost sad i'll be honest
with you it was actually as an american
citizen watching that
if this is our tops if this is our top
office choices
it's [ __ ] sad donald trump is the
greatest heel president of all time it's
almost
it's almost as if ric flair was
president he might as well just go
after everything he says he makes it
that way he
his whole game plan was to make it a
[ __ ] show to interrupt to go personal
and it's like it's really sad that
democrats have had like
three and a half years to to figure it
out like all you got to do is just
ignore it and talk
policy but they get sucked into the back
and forth and then
when you look at all the play-by-play
the next day it's
all about trump whether it's make
america great again people saying how he
won and how
they loved them or it's about how he
interrupted and how
you know um biden told him he was the
worst president of all time he called
him a clown
whatever it is it's about trump and
that's how trump wins
if you would have just stuck to saying
this is what i'm gonna do
this is what i've done this is what we
did during the obama
biden eight year run and just kept it
simple
every time he interrupted he just waited
nodded his head
stepped stuck to policy and tried to win
over the undecided voters
because they were both just [ __ ]
playing to the people whose minds are
already made up
the people who are undecided saw nothing
that's gonna change your opinion
yeah i think i don't think anything is
gonna really be swayed
but i will tell you this if it hurt
anybody last night
in my opinion and you know me i'm a
middle of the road kid i think the far
left and the far right are really wild
but you're a sicilian kid and you think
that if if
if donnie t was in the mafia he'd be put
down his mouth is too big right
if i have to be honest as a kid who's
sicilian as a kid who kind of knows
you know about how it would go down if
the kid was
uh if the kid was in the mob he would
have been put down because of the corona
thing here's the deal
if donald trump make and this is the
truth okay and i know that this is a
saying
that you and chrissy do a lot so i'm
gonna do it since i'm on the show
make no mistake about this if donnie t
was in the mob they would have put him
in a trunk and he would have went for a
ride and nobody would have saw him again
because of the handling of corona it's
just
that's what what would really have
happened um
but i think if it hurt anybody last
night
it was trump especially not denouncing
white supremacy when he had a perfectly
perfectly good chance and a perfectly
good opportunity
for all the people that say things about
him and being
you know pro-white supremacists and all
that
all he needed to do in that one moment
when chris wallace said will you are you
willing
to denounce white supremacy right now he
goes what do you want me to do
and then he goes well okay yeah fine
stand down stand by it's like
that's to me if it did hurt anybody
it hurt trump last night i think people
were like wait a minute
he can't denounce a [ __ ] bigotry hate
group
so to me that seems a little like nuts
and
uh it was a real [ __ ] what can you
say man as an american it was an
embarrassment
it was an absolute [ __ ] embarrassment
i could not wait for it to be over yeah
there's high school debates probably for
class president that had more decorum
last night
let's take a peek at [ __ ] chito
santino
saying it calling out antifa
and other left-wing extremist groups but
are you willing
tonight to condemn white supremacists
and militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared to specifically
do it i would say almost everything i
see
is from the left wing not from the right
because sure are willing to do it
just do it you don't got to say sure i'm
willing to do it that's what he already
asked you now you're stalling
because you're figuring out how you're
going to say it because you do like to
throw your dog whistles he's such a
narcissist he may not even
be a white supremacist we don't know i
think he's such a narcissist he knows
those guys vote for him
or would vote for him so he's kind
trying to figure out a way right
handed to him because if you tell trump
you like him
you can even have like a dead baby that
you say you just killed as long as you
say you know what i think you're a good
president he's going to go you know what
you're okay in my book yeah that's
exactly that's all he wants he's like
an insecure child who yeah he
he just wants if the funniest thing is
the guy like trump
he really does just want approval like
trump is the type of guy that like just
want to go you know like just hug him
rub his back and just whisper dude it's
all right you're gonna be all right you
know
people love you you know he he's a very
he's a narcissistic guy
i think too giannis i really believe
that
um he just went in a little panicked
last night i think he went
in like on i need to do more it's like
what you said about biden it was the
same with trump it's like
just wait for the question give the best
answer
you know i was talking to somebody today
that goes why didn't trump just denounce
white supremacy
and talk about the economy was doing
great it's going to do great again
he should have talked about how jobs
were going good he should have talked
about how jobs
you know with minorities and how we're
going better
he should have talked about that and
instead it was like you did this your
son did this
you're it was just a [ __ ] name game
dude my wife and i
like it that borderline that that debate
like
made me not get lucky last night with my
wife because my wife and i were sitting
in bed together and i'm going off it's
been a while since we sat together this
could be good maybe we bond over this
thing
and she got so upset she [ __ ] just
rolled over went to bed
so this thing [ __ ] blocked me too it was
so bad i got [ __ ] blocked and i don't
know
what's going on in my country yeah i
mean that's probably
i mean if there's the crime that
happened last night it's it's a lot of
[ __ ]
it's the mersey household went silent
last night you know
and that's the mercy household
i thought it was i thought it might be
good kids went down at nine
stacy and i we hop into bed we're
putting this thing on we're maybe gonna
and then it was just like we just
literally watched what do they call a
dumpster fire yeah i mean we just
watched a full-fledged [ __ ] storm
at the highest levels of our government
and we just went to bed confused
sad and scared at least it unified
i think it unified the country in
everyone uh
admitting the fact that it was an
absolute [ __ ] show i think no matter
which candidate you're going to vote for
everyone can agree that that was
a [ __ ] [ __ ] show